we have breaking news from paris where
there has been a new attack near the
newspaper office where
islamic extremists murdered 12 people
five years ago this time
two people were slashed in a knife
attack and our charlie daggett is in
london following all this
charlie this is the charlie hebdo
offices what do we know about it
well this is a developing news story we
have to point out but as far as you know
police say the attacker has been
arrested
after the knifing that took place near
the former offices of charlie hebdo
staff had been receiving death threats
since the trial got underway 14 people
suspected of helping the gunman in that
2015 attack of the magazine
that killed 12 people in a separate
attack at a jewish supermarket
two days later now earlier this month
the magazine actually republished the
controversial cartoons of the prophet
muhammad that drew
condemnation from several muslim
countries and al qaeda militants
threatened a repeat
of that 2015 massacre that initial
assault on the charlie
hebdo offices uh heralded a wave of
attacks throughout france that claimed
more than 250 lives again to recap
as far as we know the attacker has been
arrested at least two people have been
injured with life-threatening injuries
thank you very much charlie daggett i
know you'll
stay on top of that story for us thank
you